nathan is with us in more moab on Utah
hey Nathan how are you doing fine thank
you good how can I help
pleasure to speak with you I have a car
loan that we're about three thousand
dollars upside down on my wife is
apprehensive about selling the car
because then we won't have a car to show
for it
and have a three thousand dollar loan I
told her we could buy a beater
temporarily just but because of our
location we do want / need something
reliable because it helps in our
location we live very far from a lot of
places and and and traveling is is sort
of a necessity
now you have one gear one vehicle we do
have one vehicle yes
okay and what do you owe on your car
twelve thousand okay and what's your
household income household income it is
about seventy five thousand yeah
you have any debt other than your house
and this car a credit card debt at about
sixteen thousand okay all right
no I don't think you need to sell your
car okay I don't think it's I don't
think it's the problem cutting up your
credit cards tonight would be a good
idea
I did that two weeks ago yay we're on
track yeah I think the two of you get on
a budget and say we have eighteen
thousand dollars in debt and you said
you make seventy-five seventy-five years
yeah you make seventy-five we have
eighteen if I look at eighteen out of 75
I think that sounds like a one-year deal
to me all right
beans and rice rice and beans no no life
and all that traveling you've been doing
probably and gonna happen traveling is a
necessity for know just to help to know
you're in a very very remote situation I
understand I'm joking with you but my
point is you know we're gonna spend as
little as we can possibly spend so that
eighteen out of 75 becomes very doable
by the way that's 1500 a month you can
do that perfect like one year you're
100% debt-free you keep the car you
don't keep the credit cards perfect good
good job man
you got this